et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
ghislaine pierrât docteur en
communication politique bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
frédéric sinclair politologue et
écrivain bonsoir à vous aussi enfin
alexis poulin et éditorialiste merci à
tous les trois d'être en direct sur rt
france on aborde tout d'abord le cas de
la côte d'azur où vous trouvez
d'ailleurs frédéric saint clair parce
qu'il ya un match en paca qui est l'un
des plus attendus de ce second tour mon
amo dès lors nous en parle et celui
entre le président sortant les
républicains et candidat du
rassemblement national la gauche a
décidé de soutenir nos muselier une
alliance dénoncé par thierry mariani
vous propose de l'écouter
je ne vais pas chercher des socialistes
les communistes où les écolos dingo ça
c'est ce que fait renaud muselier
il sait qu'il peut perdre donc il se
compromet dans une alliance de sortants
qui veulent protéger leur poste alors ce
front républicain contre quand on en a
déjà évidemment entendu parler mais
frédéric sinclair quid des électeurs est
ce qu'on respecte leur libre choix avec
ses arrangements qui donne parfois
l'impression que les politiques pensent
peut-être avant tout c'est vrai à leur
poste quand on a pris le temps d'écouter
le la passe d'armes entre feliz ya donc
le représentant de l'union des gauches
en paca et muselier on se rend bien
compte qu'on est sur deux lignes
radicalement différente la critique que
le tête de liste d'union des gauches à
opérer de la politique mené par renaud
muselier pendant ces cinq années
si l'année a été a été radical donc
évidemment le premier soir au moment de
l' annonce des résultats
la première décision c'est le respect
des électeurs pour la liste d'union de
gauche et donc pas d'alliance et puis la
pression des apparatchiks parisiens
que ce soit chez eux élevés ou au ps ont
contraint
finalement le candidat de paca à se
rallier à la voix de la raison entre
guillemets et finalement à faire une
alliance là on sent bien que il ya eu
une tension et surtout en paca le
monstre mariani fait fait de moins en
moins peur pour deux raisons
premièrement c'est que la
dédiabolisation du rassemblement
rassemblement national est largement
entamée donc on ne craint plus vraiment
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a plusieurs
mairies qui sont gérés par des mères
rassemblement national donc on ne craint
plus du tout que ce soit le diable
la deuxième raison c'est que mariani et
en l air est donc globalement dans la
tête des électeurs en paca on commence à
se dire que finalement si demain marine
le pen arrivait au pouvoir ce serait
aussi des ministres et l'eire qui
gouvernerait comme ça a été le cas pour
macron alors si on pas car on court
après les voix de gauche c'est pas du
tout le cas évidemment dans la région
ile de france où les listes europe
écologie les verts ps et la france
insoumise s'unissent pour tenter de
faire barrage cette fois ci est la
présidente sortant et les républicains
qui est arrivé largement en tête du
premier tour une alliance qui inquiète
valérie pécresse on écoute le bloc de
gauche est en mesure de venir nous
concurrencer il faut tout faire pour
faire barrage à cette alliance qui a
perdu sa boussole républicaine la lfp a
franchi les limites du pacte républicain
une attaque en règle la part de valérie
pécresse on la comprend un petit peu
énervé valérie pécresse est la raison
d'être inquiète
alexis poulain je sais pas s'il a raison
d'être inquiète parce que l'union des
gauches n'a jamais vraiment déboucher
sur des scores faramineux dans les urnes
donc ça permet de mobiliser on va dire
ses troupes de dirk attention le danger
est là je pourrais perdre donc il ne
faudrait pas croire que le second tour
ait gagné face à cette union de la
gauche donc elle est clairement dans une
logique de mobilisation de l'électorat
et donc c'est pour ça qu'elle prend un
peu cette posture alarmiste alors que je
pense qu'il ya pas de soucis à se faire
pour elle face à ce second tour
les attaques sont assez assez
caricatural est assez politicienne cette
bonne guerre également dans ce second
tour il va falloir lâcher tous les
chevaux et est vraiment ceux marqués
très fort à droite ou très fort à gauche
est vraiment montrer qu'il ya un intérêt
à aller voter parce que c'est deux camps
différents et que la région est bien
allé politique même si elle est surtout
à organiser la vie quotidienne les
transports etc
il ya quand même là un enjeu politique
important surtout pour valeriquais
presque et qui a dit que si elle ne
gagnait pas elle se retirait non
seulement de la course à la
présidentielle mais de la vie politique
tout simplement
donc si elle perd c'est fini pour elle
elle devra quitter le champ politique
national donc elle a mis un enjeu énorme
dans cette élection donc elle a intérêt
à ce que non seulement elle gagne mais
qu'elle gagne avec un score important
sans ça ce serait une sanction et il
serait difficile pour elle ensuite de se
lancer dans une investiture ou dans une
course à la présidentielle face à xavier
bertrand qui lui est assuré de faire un
un excellent score en région nord est
qui a déjà lancé sa campagne bien en
amont donc vraiment est là elle est elle
en train de jouer un va-tout vraiment
ses cartes sur table pour ces régionales
et si jamais le score n'était pas à la
hauteur
ce serait très difficile pour elle
ensuite de faire valoir une candidature
d'exception pour les républicains
sachant que révoqué est également en
embuscade on ne l'entend pas on ne le
voit pas mais il a fait un score
excellent sur ce premier tour malgré
l'abstention massive
il reste qu'on confond conforté dans sa
région et lui aussi a des ambitions pour
on aurait vu d'autres un alexis dire
fontaine et finalement revenir à la
source
gsm sera la grande gagnante évidemment
on l'a dit c'est l'abstention se sentent
6,1 pour cent des français ne sont pas
allés voter ça monte jusqu'à 87 % chez
chez les jeunes le chiffre est
impressionnant c'est quoi c'est la
communication du gouvernement qui a été
défaillante au tour de cette élection ou
est ce parce qu'il ya tout simplement un
désamour entre les français et les urnes
grandissant alors pour être honnête
intellectuellement il faut quand même
dire que ce cycle abstentionniste a
commencé déjà en 2008 est bon il s'est
amplifié et avec cette élection on
atteint des scores absolument inédit
nous sommes bien d'accord mais les
français ont fait une grève la grève des
urnes sans préavis
et ils n'ont il faut dire
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit la
communication politique
elle est datée elle est désuète et elle
est complètement inadapté alors d'une
part vous avez une communication
politique qui doit être absolument
revisité parce que vous vous rappelez
que michel rocard et guy carcassonne
avec complètement muselé la communique
la publicité et la communication
politique
et puis d'autre part il y a eu aucun
modernisme bon sur cette élection
les les procurations en ligne ont pas
été possible bon il n'y a pas eu de vote
électronique etc
donc on avait cessé deux pénalités qui
ont fait que ça a joué également alors
bien évidemment je ne dis pas que c'est
que la communication ou la publicité
politique qui est datée et qui a
pénalisé qui a fait ce score il ya des
raisons profondes
nous avons sur le plateau d des
politologues et c'est donc il ya bien
sûr des raisons politiques mais moi dans
mon dos n'est en qualité de spin doctor
jeudi que également la publicité et la
communication politique ont joué un rôle
frédéric saint clair en tout cas
emmanuel macron demi s'est pas vraiment
exprimé un sur sept abstentions alors
que jean castex a dû réagir à libyen a
dû réagir parce qu'on sentait ce matin
que voilà l'abstention s'était pas
vraiment là la faute du gouvernement il
a fini par appeler à l'humilité le
premier ministre parce qu'il a été
interpellé un par la droite notamment
mais on ne sent pas une remise en cause
très importante à part de ce
gouvernement cette abstention ce n'est
pas leur faute ils n'y sont pour rien ce
gouvernement castex c'est assez
intéressant cette question de
l'abstention il y a en réalité un un
loup cacher derrière qui est le
caractère sacré du peuple en démocratie
donc à partir du moment où vous dites
que la démocratie repose sur
l'assentiment du peuple et que vous
faites
la voix du peuple l'essentiel la base le
fondement de toute votre institution
politique au moment où le peuple vous
méprise vous avez un problème parce
qu'en réalité c'est l'ensemble du
système qui méprisent et c'est ce qui
s'est passé là les français n'ont pas
seulement dit on n'a pas envie de voter
pour vous parce que vous nous
intéressait pas même si c'est vrai ils
n'ont pas seulement dit on n'y comprend
rien à ce millefeuille administratif et
en plus de ça il ne change pas vraiment
la vie de nos régions de nos de notre
quotidien
même si c'est vrai ils n'ont pas
seulement 10 il ya eu un cafouillage
tels que je n'ai même pas reçu les
professions de foi deux jours avant j'ai
pas eu le temps de les regarder bref
donc mais ils ont aussi dit je vais
aller me promener
c'est à dire je vais profiter de ma vie
de citoyen et mon investissement ma vie
de domme d'homme public et de deux dom
privée je veux dire mon investissement
citoyen je le laisse de côté il y à il
ya quelque part un désaveu de tout
système démocratique les français ont
manqué à leurs responsabilités
donc il ya une part qui s'explique il ya
une part qui leur incombent
mais la part qui leur incombent le
gouvernement ne veut pas y toucher et
dire que on ne veut jamais stigmatiser
les français la seule qui a osé le faire
c'est marine le pen est elle s'est fait
taper sur les doigts par une partie de
ses cadres parce que ça ne se fait pas
d'aller reproché aux électeurs de ne pas
être venus voter pour soi donc on est
dans une situation extrêmement
compliquée justement frédéric 5e l'un de
ses cadres à enliser dans les colonnes
du figaro ce matin qui disait pas son
nom apparemment avait une analyse de
cette question de l'extension alexis
blanc puisqu'il me disais oh maintenant
qu'on les électeurs ne sont plus
contents tout simplement ils ne vont
plus voter alors qu'à l'époque
nouveautés rns que vous partagez ce
cette analyse de ce cadre qui s'ils
n'ont parlé sous couvert d'anonymat
oui je trouve que c'est une analyse
assez justes il y avait un danger dans
la stratégie de marine le pen de
dédiabolisation de devenir une candidate
mainstream de droite un classique
cette perdre son électorat populaire qui
est un électorat est extrêmement volatil
parce que c'est un électorat difficiles
à mobiliser on l'a vu est extrêmement
difficile à faire venir
tu es mais aussi qui est très volatile
qui peut passer d'un candidat à un autre
parce que celui ci a beaucoup trop
changé et marine le pen de 2021 2022
elle n'a rien à voir avec marine le pen
de la campagne de 2010 est elle a
totalement changé à la fois son discours
sur l'europe sur l'euro sur l'économie
surtout les fondamentaux il ne reste
qu'une chose c'est l'immigration mais
tout le monde est en train de contester
ce débat d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire
ml macron sans grand succès d'ailleurs
mais c'est ce que pourrait faire l air
avec succès donc elle est menacée dans
sa stratégie de dédiabolisation elle le
sait et ce n'est pas en attaquant les
électeurs qu'ils n'ont pas compris
qu'ils devraient se mobiliser pour voter
pour elle qu'elle valait faire voter
pour elle bien au contraire je crois que
c'est contreproductif et qu'elle est en
train de perdre parce que derrière cette
affiche de 2022 vendus par beaucoup de
deux sondeurs et d'un sondage macro le
pen le match retour
il y à une réalité qui n'existe pas
c'est une réalité alternative de vouloir
que ce match arrive mais il excelle dans
un an
beaucoup de choses peuvent se passer on
voit comment l'électorat volatile
comment ils sanctionnent dès maintenant
marine le pen est d'ailleurs la guerre
interne aura l'assemblée nationale est
importante avec une nouvelle garde qui
veut évacuer l'ancienne garde trop
proches de certains milieux néo-nazis
etc qui font tâche donc c'est vraiment
compliqué pour elle de gérer ce parti
c'est vraiment compliqué pour elle et le
résultat d'ailleurs de ces régionales
pourraient handicaper sa candidature ou
sa stature d'opposant officielle à
emmanuel macron alors ajustements
emmanuel macron lui c'est pas mieux
alors qu'on voyait déjà la
présidentielle un mec rond le pen en
tout cas pour ces régionales un pas
mieux chloé rennes
c'est cet échec spectaculaire de la
république en marche le parti des
manuels mais cros exemple dans les hauts
de france où la liste de laurent pietra
c'est ce qui fait moins de 10 % il est
recalé dès le premier tour regarder
l'enseignement qu'en tire justement le
président la raim au sénat françois
patriat ce mouvement et trop virtuel on
est trop dans l'antre soit on n'a pas
des militants on a des cliques coeur
j'essai ne sert à vous la spécialiste de
la communication
c'est ça le problème de la république
heures marche ils sont trop dans le
virtuel pas assez d'ancrage de terrain
alors en fait vous avez raison de
relever ça parce que c'est un paradoxe
on a vu que bon quand emmanuel macron a
été élu c'était très actif
c'était une élection où les réseaux
sociaux avait été abondamment utilisé et
là ils n'ont pas su faire le suivi non
vous savez dans les grandes villes
il n'y a même pas de permanence en
marche
donc il n'ya pas le lien social ni
physique ni virtuel ni dans dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est ça c'est tout
effiloché et c'est assez curieux de voir
qu'ils ont refusé la modernisation de
cette élection des cantonales et
régionales et que en plus tout ce qui
avait fait le succès de en marche n'a
pas continué frédéric saint clair la
même analyse
effectivement complètement il y a du
point de vue de du parti présidentiel
non seulement un échec à à s'ancrer dans
les territoires mais un échec ce
simplement à parler aux citoyens et a
délégué la le charisme on va on va dire
quand même parce qu'il est là le cari
emmanuel macron à utiliser à bon escient
en 2017 et qu'il a peu à peu perdu
jusqu'à devenir aujourd'hui un président
en difficulté comme le disait tout à
l'heure
alexis poulain on a vendu une en grande
partie le l'affrontement 2022 on a
survendu l'affrontement 2022
emmanuel macron marine le pen cet
affrontement été grandement
instrumentalisé par emmanuel macron et
qui a fracturé la droite qui a fracturé
la gauche pour récupérer les partis
libéral et avoir face à lui simplement
une gauche dite extrême avec jean luc
mélenchon le pif et les fit et le parti
communiste
et puis à à droite le rassemblement
national ce qui faciliterait une
potentielle réélection donc on a un
parti présidentiel qui ne tient que sur
la figure évanescente du président
justement l'excès poulain ce n'est pas
le problème justement d' emmanuel macron
lui-même et de sa personne un charisme
une modernité qui s'est transformée
peut-être une forme d'arrogance en tout
cas pour certains français qui le qui ne
reçoivent comme ça je crois que c'est
une promesse déçu e mails macron qui
essayent de raccrocher les wagons avec
la jeunesse et qui hier soir de fête de
la musique envoie la police à la chasse
aux jeunes sur les quais et partout il
faisait la fête tandis que l'ue organise
une une rave party à l'elysée pour des
seniors décoré de médailles
donc il ya un hiatus il c'est un
président vraiment hors sol c'est
assumer la rupture est totale je pense
qu'il est même politiquement mort ce
soir
suite aux régionales et à cette
incapacité de raccrocher alors il y aura
une campagne communicationnelle le
discours du 14 juillet la déambulation
qui va continuer avec ces des
privatisations de village d'une semaine
en scène tel un bon roi venant voir ces
sujets bienveillant mais ça ne
fonctionne pas il ya eu la claque
atteint qui est arrivé de manière
impromptue et donc tout là toute la
communication la façon dont il voulait
être maître des horloges tout ça est
passé totalement à l'asse fini pour pour
lui d'une certaine façon parce que là ça
fait quand même deux sur intermédiaires
ou la république en marche et à moins de
4 % du corps électoral c'est à dire
qu'on a un parti qui n'existe pas c'est
un parti virtuel c'est ce que dit
d'ailleurs monsieur patriat
on n'a pas de militants on a des
clippers les cadres sont très peu
nombreux il y a certes des députés qui
ont été placés la suite à la
présidentielle avec législatives dans la
foulée mais qui sont en train de
réfléchir à la suite de ce mandat
certains ne vont pas se représenter pour
beaucoup d'ailleurs
et certains même de se demande ce qu'ils
font encore dans une majorité
présidentielle qui a viré à droite très
rapidement alors qu'il venait du parti
socialiste donc il y à vraiment la une
une erreur politique fondamentale des
malais mâcon qui veut tout incarner tout
tout est tout centraliser que ce soit la
gestion de la crise sanitaire que ce
soit la gestion de la crise des gilets
jaunes et tout devrait passer par lui
le premier ministre est de passage il
n'est même pas dans une fonction de
paratonnerre on le voit on va très bien
il est dans une fonction de porte-parole
quasiment et puis cette volonté presque
psychédélique de vouloir parler à tout
le monde de manière archipel is et les
jeunes
les électeurs de droite voire d'extrême
droite essayait de rameuter le maximum
de personnes alors qu'il n'y a pas de
colonne vertébrale et surtout qu'il n'ya
plus de vision aujourd'hui la seule
vision des mêmes mâcon c'est est-ce que
je peux être réglée sur un nouveau coup
politique comme 2017 or c'est impossible
il devra défendre un bilan et ce bilan
aujourd'hui il est difficilement
défendable
g saint pierre a le mot de la fin pour
vous voulez à la présidentielle avec ces
régionales est bel et bien lancée 2022
mais pas du tout avec les cartes qu'on
imagine et on part de zéro ou c'est trop
tôt pour le dire
ben en fait je voudrais revenir aussi
sur quelque chose bon là on est à dix
mois de la présidentielle
donc évidemment cette élection régionale
a une dimension extrêmement symbolique
mais bon pour mettre un bémol
vous savez je crois que cette claque de
l'abstention elle touche tout le monde
la preuve en est c'est que au front
national
ils ont énormément de jeunes or les
jeunes ils n'ont pas voté non plus au
front national
donc bon bien sûr que branché chez makro
ils sont touchés mais ça touche tout le
monde
donc il ya une remise en cause et
l'enseignement qu'on peut en tirer je
crois que chacun sera d'accord c'est que
c'est pour ça qu'il ya une effervescence
journalistique politique là dessus c'est
que cette élection régionale elle rebat
les cartes vraiment elle ouvre le champ
électoral
on voit les anciens eux partis qui
résiste bon le les républicains sur un
parti de résistants ils peuvent
remporter cette région la gauche
balaient débrouille pas trop mal et elle
montre son ancrage local et elle peut
récupérer peut-être cinq régions donc là
l'enseignement que l'on tire des
régionales et qui va impacter pour la
présidentielle c'est que l rebattre
complètement les cartes et personne ne
s'attendait à ce que ces régionales
rebattre les cartes pour la
présidentielle et est très rapidement
frédéric cinq ans parce qu'on arrive à
la fin du débat il faut bien se dire
aussi avec un pendage dans les grandes
largeurs si je peux m'exprimer ainsi 2
nos amis son dard je crois pas c'est
vrai que les sondeurs sont passés à côté
mais en fait ils sont passés à côté de
l'abstention juste en un mot marine le
pen c'est 900 mille voix 900 milles en
2015 dans la région hôte france à
l'époque nord pas de calais
sébastien chenu c'est à peine 200 ou 250
milles ou peut-être 300 mille voix donc
vous rendez compte il manque 600 mille
voix entre chenu et et le pen juste pour
ça wauquiez c'est la même chose il perd
5 200 mille cinquante mille voix jeux de
mémoire il ya en réalité c'est je pense
qu'ils ont complètement raté
le taux d'abstention qui a été beaucoup
plus grand que ce qu'ils anticipaient et
c'est là que vraiment ils sont trompés
c'est effectivement leur axe de défense
entre guillemets merci à tous les trois
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce cette
analyse passionnante